So here we are back in the self driving car.
Katy, what have we learned this unit?
>> We've learned so much, we've come so far.
We've learned three supervised classification algorithms.
And we've also learned a lot of things that are more higher level than just
the algorithms themselves.
We've learned about bias and variance.
These are two extremely important ideas in machine learning.
We've learned about over-fitting.
We've learned about the parameters.
How you can take an algorithm and
make it look completely different just using the parameters.
We've covered a lot of material.
>> That sounds so amazing.
So when you get to it like in [INAUDIBLE].
What really makes a great machine learning researcher?
>> A great machine learning researcher is someone who's really excited and
curious and adventurous and they have a lot of questions and
they really want to answer them.
And what it does when you have this attitude is, it makes you go out and
find the way that you can answer the question that you have.
And you have a really great start with the stuff that we've taught you.
But there's a lot of stuff that we haven't taught you.
Machine learning is a gigantic topic.
And a great machine learning researcher is somebody who goes out after this and
tries stuff on their own.
That's how you learn.
>> So my last question.
I have a hunch. Is this what the next unit is all about?
>> Your hunches are usually correct, Sebastian, and
in, in this case it is again.
In the next unit, we're going to be talking about data sets,
we're going to be talking about questions.
We've talked a lot about algorithms that are very important, but
at the heart of it machine learning is about the data that you have and
the questions that you're trying to answer with it.
And we're going to really dig into this topic.
And I'm very excited.
We have a new dataset we're going to be looking at.
It's the Enron dataset.
It's a really interesting case of emails and
fraud, and we're going to be taking a really deep look at this dataset,
trying to figure out what we can get out of it.
That's totally amazing, I guess we'll see you in class.
>> I hope so, we'll see you in class.